et nous accueillons maintenant
ici les dix inédits bob away
à
alors bon soir bonsoir
tu as quel âge l'a63 tu sais que tu vas
bientôt bientôt effective l'institution
maintenant oui par les dans le who's who
un petit larousse dans le petit robert
al haouz pas compliqué ouais ça tombe
bien c'est devenu naturel bernatchez
comptant alors de 14 à 18 ans tu es allé
à l'école estienne tu as appris appelé
les métiers d'art et ce qui est plus
rigolo c'est que de 19 à 22 ans a été
chanteur dans un groupe qui s'appelle et
garçons de la rue était est et nord
chanter quoi quartier north je sais pas
j'ai chanté quoi je chantais dans près
en chanteurs du pré vert du caveau des
trucs comme ça t'en souviens pas non ce
serait incapable de chanter là
incapables j'ai déjà apprécié et a
chanté d'envoi comme ça ça a duré deux
ans que résidence jusqu'à ce que l'armée
m'appelle alors justement l'armée ça
fait l'armée c'est là que tu as pris ton
dégoût de l'armée s'est alarmé ouais
donc j'avais déjà un peu à peu alors en
54 a eu le grand prix d'humour noir
pourquoi j'ai commencé mes dessins après
l'armée ouais ma passion du moment c'est
ce que je cultive l'art mais les
militaires les flics enfin tout ça
rentrait dans le truc il se trouve que
tout d'un coup un jury c'est assez
dingue pour faire ça venait de sortir en
fait c'était la pression'' ans c'était
la seconde fois ce conte qui décernait
le prion et en 55 tu as fait un livre
sur les chars qui était un best seller
international sa a vendu combien on
attend on attend deux millions on fera
les réponses en disant que c'est fait
beaucoup d'argent avec ça ouais c'est
apprendre premier pognon ouais et de
maisons à la campagne une bagnole enfin
c'est tout un bon après ça a baissé de
ces été traduit dans plein de pays et
comment on pouvait traduire chat machin
ne s'est pas tout à fait traduit ces
bains avec 4 imaginerait alcatraz
cathédrale
donc les dessins changé mais le gredin
le principe est tellement en allemand
fabrication novembre ouais de 13 mai 58
tu faisais ton premier dessin politique
dans l'express c'était quoi
c'était une série comme les chats mais
sur youtube ou para a mis d'accord et
oui les part à cette aventure arrive à
réaliser apparaissent booba est alors en
novembre 62 tu quittes l'express
parce que tu dis que c'est pas assez de
gauche pourtant à l'express à l'époque
c'était de gauche maintenant c'est vrai
que ça n'est plus du tout mais à
l'époque c'était quand même un journal
pour l'algérie algérienne sans faste et
très militant pas trop c'était en mai
c'était humaniste au prince mais de
celle à gauche bien bien pensants vrai
c'était pas extrémiste c'était pas des
voyous parce que pour l'algérie qu'est
ce que vous voulez de plus que ce que
voulaient les gens de l'express vous
voulez l'indépendance de l'algérie
étaient les accords avec ça toi bien sûr
oui mais bon à jouer avec ça aille plus
vite
avant j'étais pas contre le fait de
prendre des armes pour lutter contre les
français et un ami il était contre les
tortures mais c'est tout en fait nous
n'était pas compte tellement contre la
guerre way contre le colonialisme
c'était contre la façon dont les
françaises conduisait dont tu as été un
porteur de valises du fln
qu'est ce tu as fait à cette époque
prend une valeur qui l'amène à loin que
c'est passé simple simplement les
algériens se faisait arrêter avec leur
leur faciès ouais donc à nous avec notre
onze de francs carillon et aujourd'hui
tu penses quoi de l'algérie trente ans
après 62
je suis content qu'elle soit
indépendante oui d'accord mais qu'est ce
que tu prends la situation politique en
algérie hma suis ravi qu'ils enterrent
d'une fils quand ils ont gagné les
élections quoi je serais aussi d'accord
pour éliminer le front national dans le
même genre d'idée je suis content
démocratie qu'il est ce que tu penses
que le suffrage universel a des limites
mais qui fixe et limite les copains et
cuba alors tu as été très marqué avec
cuba alors en 62 a été reçu plusieurs
mois à cuba à 9 61 61
on est allé voir castro ouais tu l'as vu
souvent non une fois sk des journaux par
exemple dans paris presse de l'époque on
dit qu'il ya eu une longue entrevue avec
castro etc
et puis un autre journal où tu dis je
les rencontrais l'aéroport et je lui ai
dit c'est lou dos la vérité c'est quoi
cette che guevara che guevara que j'ai
rencontré rapidement aéroports
cédric fidèles j'ai eu une longue
conversation un truc donc tu fais pas
fait pas ton ppda la tulle a vraiment
rencontré il était sympa révolte est là
en 85 et vu un scandale quand même tu
t'en souviens c'était un peu bourré sur
carbone 14 une radio libre comme on
disait à l'époque
et puis tu as dit que après sabra et
chatila finalement tu comprenais le la
rue des rosiers enfin tu pouvais
l'admettre dany ça tue le regrette mme
avant de la voir des gens votent la
façon dont j'ai riposté pas passer du
tout ouais mais c'est pas du tout ça
j'aurais envie de dire pour moi
testament vidéo
oui c'est vrai qu'après ça braille
surface et même pas après ça avant
pendant et après c'est toujours été
contre la politique menée par israël sur
le conte avec les palestiniens mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut dire le
mot j'ai fait moi
sillonnez ses doigts verts passés les
gens mélangent tout ils font un amalgame
d'ailleurs bien des gens prétendent être
antisioniste et on est aussi antisémite
je suis pas d'accord moi je suis anti
sioniste vraiment comment dit on comme
les communistes étaient ya un mot pour
faire non
tout est comme une primaire je suis anti
suis preneur je suis pas content et
celui contre lille contre israël à la
limite s'ils étaient de gauche ce serait
d'accord avec sais pas s'ils sont de
droite ne s'est pas d'accord la licra
porter plainte
le front d'action juifs aussi l'avis
crête à pardonner après mais le fait
qu'ils ont passé l'épongé
en fait il j'ai fait une lettre à ré ils
m'ont demandé une lettre d' excuses il
laissé tomber les poursuites
j'ai fait une lettre qu'ils ont publiées
tout s'est bien passé sauf que des
jeunes excités on continue que le procès
comme un point ici dis moi tu as fait un
bouquin sur la cia ou pour être jamais
fait de bouquins sur le kgb par exemple
senti mentalement j'étais pour c'était
un peu stalinien comme on dirait des
stalles et m'attends toujours un peu bah
oui ça va passer j'ai toujours un petit
côté sentimental aux lettres maintenant
faudrait pas que ça pouvait énerver les
gens maintenant c'est touchant aux fonds
tepa anarchiste aux fonds non au foncier
ouais c'est pas facile d'exprimer son
anarchie je suis un peu comme coluche
peut quand même un coluche et pour les
en fait j'aurais retiré de l'échantillon
c'est ça le fondement de mon frère on va
en a dans l'équipe nous d'anarchistes
s'appelle laurent baffie sur l'argile
montre un truc qu'il a fait